thank you
[Applause]
after six months of picket lines and
hundreds of thousands of canceled
operations and appointments finally an
agreement on a pay deal for NHS workers
so I'm pleased that the majority of
Health unions
um that members accepted the
recommendations we made that it was the
it was the best alternative to waiting
for the pay review body process to run
out for this year the hope is that
lessons have been learned about the
value of of listening to NHS staff the
deal means more than a million NHS staff
will get a five percent increase and a
lump sum possibly as soon as June but
unions are divided unite and the Royal
College of Nursing will re-ballot
members like Mark over further strike
action I can't you know go to the
students who I train and say yeah I
think you're going to have a well-paid
profession a good career ahead of you
based on based on this pay deal and it
you know it just makes it was just going
to create more anger the way the
government have handled this imposing it
on people not not open reopening
negotiations it's just made people more
more angry and frustrated but the
government says the matter is now
settled this was a decision taken by 14
Health unions they reached a majority
decision it was negotiated collectively
the RCN were at the negotiating table
indeed Pat Cullen recommended this deal
to her own members so it's important
that everyone now respects the decision
as
after the health
viewer there are some difficult
questions ahead for the rtn and unite
and the government will see this
breakthrough as proof that it can
negotiate a deal with the junior doctors
a pay deal reached but long-term issues
remaining including a record patient
waiting list and still no Workforce plan
to address the crisis in the Recruitment
and Retention of NHS staff
y Sky News in central London